en Líbano Cómo llega este acuerdo
teniendo en cuenta la crisis económica
que sufre desde 2019
sin duda de este acuerdo le va a
permitir muchos beneficios al Líbano
pero no tenemos que olvidar que digamos
de aquí a que comience a poder monetizar
de alguna manera los ingresos derivados
de de de este acuerdo para pasar por lo
menos cinco o seis años no entonces bien
de primera medida
le diría que hay que ser cautos en
cuanto al impacto y la alegría que o el
positivismo que esto puede generar en la
comunidad libanesa No ahora ayudará este
acuerdo a reducir las tensiones y los
riesgos de un conflicto entre ambos
países
sin duda el acuerdo nos da nos ha
sorprendido a más de uno pero también
hay que tener en cuenta que el acuerdo
fue viabilizado porque es volada nada de
lo que hace es de manera de consulta con
por lo que de alguna manera tenemos el
Ok de Irán que ha permitido que este que
este acuerdo se lleva adelante es un
hito positivo en las relaciones entre
los dos estados pero dudo que lleve a un
acuerdo de paz permanente en relación
digamos
frente a los vínculos que conectan el
Líbano con Siria queda de alguna manera
impide la concreción de un acuerdo de
paz por separado entre ambos países
digamos es decir no es posible que sigue
Dios nos realiza un acuerdo de paz con
Israel por separado No creo que estén
las condiciones dadas para que Siria
realice un acuerdo por lo tanto tampoco
creo que el Líbano lo hará sí es
simplemente creo una manera
paliativa de alguna manera un signo de
descongelamiento digamos de las
relaciones Pero esto no va a derivar en
la realización de un acuerdo de paz
Aunque por supuesto eso signo positivo
no la cooperación entramos a Estados
claro y por otro lado están los
palestinos que rechazan el acuerdo
porque con esto le iban nos reconoce el
estado de Israel puede este pacto
desestabilizar la región
no no lo dudo Mira es muy importante que
veamos que leamos entre líneas
Cuál ha sido la palabra de por ejemplo
hace hace algunas pocas horas ha dicho
que este acuerdo no implica el
reconocimiento de fronteras definitivas
con el estado de Israel el acuerdo se ha
llevado adelante de manera indirecta con
el apoyo de los Estados Unidos han
estado los sectores militares del Líbano
fuertemente involucrados en la
realización de este pacto por lo tanto
dudo que tenga o constituya de alguna
manera una una desestabilización
para la región aunque creo que es un
signo positivo dudo que lleve a un
acuerdo de paz permanente en el mediano
plazo ahora señor chaya en Israel grupos
conservadores ya han empezado a moverse
para bloquear este acuerdo su aprobación
está totalmente ga o perdurará teniendo
en cuenta las distintas rupturas que ha
atravesado el gobierno
hoy por hoy me parece que gran desafío
frente a la aprobación de este tratado
está justamente en territorio israelino
donde los sectores más conservadores han
manifestado su desprecio por este
acuerdo no que creen que le dada una
manera entidad a las agrupaciones por
ejemplo como como como que fuera
en el Líbano En cambio ya con el con el
con el acuerdo de los sectores que mayor
resistencia pues daban un comienzo los
19 2020 cuando comenzaron las
negociaciones el camino del Líbano está
allanado no dudo de que será
aprobado Aunque está el tema está ahí
digamos todavía no fue firmado
ratificado por el presidente dicen que
el 20 de octubre aproximadamente lo va a
hacer Pero bueno el principal desafío se
encuentra hoy en la central legislativas
really sobre si vas a seguir adelante o
no con el tratado